bonsoir à tous et merci de nous
retrouver pour une nouvelle édition de
24 heures sénat on va tout de suite
prendre la direction de l'hémicycle pour
rejoindre sa verrière roseq bonsoir
savait rien bonsoir delphine les le
projet de loi de réforme de retraite et
bien poursuit son chemin au sénat où en
sont les sénateurs exactement ouais un
chemin chaotique les sénateurs vous le
savez poursuivre l'examen des articles
concernant la pénibilité
hier soir ils ont rejeté la création
d'un conte prévention pénibilité ce
système de points que l'on acquiert en
fonction de la pénibilité de son poste
et qu'on peut ensuite convertir en
formation en temps partiel ou en
retraite anticipée alors gérard longuet
pour l'ump a dénoncé l' enjeu financier
financier à la charge des entreprises
d'une telle structure
et cet après midi les sénateurs
continuent toujours d'examiner ce même
thème la prévention de la pénibilité
je vous propose tout de suite de
retrouver l'hémicycle la discussion
porte sur l'organisation de la médecine
de travail pour prendre la suite de la
discussion du projet de loi adopté par
l'assemblée nationale après engagement
de la procédure accélérée garantissant
l'avenir la justice du système de
retraite dans la discussion des articles
nous sommes parvenus à l'amendement
numéro 2 182 au sein de l'article 10
je suis saisi 24 amendement faisant
l'objet d'une discussion commune
c'est madame de roche qui présente cette
série d'amendements
enfin je veux bien présentés mais nous
avions pensé que ces amendements tombé
du fait du rejet de l'article 6 ils sont
tous retirés
non s'ils sont pas retirées je les le
281 de vous retirer
non non je voulais savoir s'il ne
tombait pas du fait de la vous pouvez
les défendre alors l'article
l'amendement 282 c'est pour modifier la
linea et non pas faire une entrée en
vigueur des articles 6 et 9 au 1er
janvier 2015 mais au 1er janvier 2017
on va pas revenir sur tout le
développement de de ce que représente le
compte personnel de prévention la vie ni
la pénibilité en terme de difficultés
d'application mais nous souhaitons un
recul de la date 6 7 a mentie ce conte
venait à être validée ultérieurement
alors la route le 281 suivant alors le
premier c'était pour les entreprises de
moins de 250 celui 286 pour les
entreprises employant moins de 50
salariés pour le 281 c'est pour moins de
20 salariés
le 318 n'est pas défendu ils tombent
donc j'ai demandé l'avis de notre
rapporteur sur les trois premiers la
présidente madame la ministre
la sénatrice vous proposé par vos
amendements successifs de différer
l'entrée en vigueur du conte prévention
du compte personnel de prévention de la
pénibilité au 1er janvier 2017 pour les
entreprises de moins de 250 de moins de
250 salariés ou de moins de 50 salariés
ou de moins de 20 salariés
je ne comprends pas le sens de ces
amendements
parce que pour les salariés qui sont
exposés à des facteurs de risque qu'ils
soient dans une entreprise de 350
salariés de 3 239 salariés de 48
salariés ou 18 salariés c'est la même
chose
donc c'est pas la taille de l'entreprise
qui détermine l'exposition au risque
mais c'est bien les postes de travail
donc c'est bien évidemment un avis
défavorable qui a été émis par la
commission sur ces trois amendements
merci même le rapporteur madame la
ministre défavorable merci je vais donc
même s'il ne signait pas d'explication
madame du rouge merci madame la
présidente j'entends bien votre réponse
madame le rapporteur mais ce sur quoi
nous avons mis l'accent hier c'était sur
les difficultés que que le comte
pénibilité général notamment pour les
tpe pme
d'où notre un moment vous ne voulez pas
entendre cet argument et vous en restez
vous restez vraiment fixés sur sur la
notion d'égalité entre toutes les
entrées toutes les entreprises quelle
que soit la taille de l'entreprise mais
nous nous ne compte des difficultés des
entreprises
et permettez moi de vous dire que
lorsqu'on on veut appliquer aux
établissements privés mais pas l'hôpital
et les mêmes les mêmes règles en matière
de pénibilité sans tenir mordicus aux
petites entreprises et ne pas
l'appliquer dans l'écran de dans des
grands secteurs publics ça n'a pas de
cohérence merci madame de roche la
parole est à monsieur longuet vous ne
prenez pas très bien très bien pas
d'autres demandes de parole je vais donc
mettre aux voix l'amendement de 182 et
reçu deux avis défavorables qui est pour
merci contre
merci chers collègues abstentions il
n'est pas adoptée même vote pour les 281
même vote
vous voulez vous exprimer je vous en
prie chaque collecte oui moi je pense
que effectivement pour les entreprises
moins de 250 salariés peut-être que on
peut s'organiser mais pour les petites
entreprises de moins de 20 salariés moi
je vais penser que 10 de 10 c'était bien
je pense que c'est beaucoup plus
difficile d'organiser ce ces fiches de
sa demande un travail aux chefs
d'entreprise qui veut ça va rebuter un
certain nombre d'entreprises de faire ce
travail
une surcharge il faudra embaucher
quelqu'un parce qu'il n'ya pas de drh
dans l'entreprise et au delà des
complications qui se surajoutent les
unes aux autres et je soutiens surtout
cet amendement 280 merci votre demande
de parole je n'en vois pas je vais le
mettre aux voix qui est poids deux avis
défavorables qui est pour
merci qui est contre merci chers
collègues abstentions il n'est pas
adopté même votre pour le 281 monsieur
longuet mais selon gay oui merci madame
le président madame le ministre mes
chers collègues
c'est évidemment un amendement de repli
des amendements précédent mais je
reprends l'intervention excellente de
mon collègue gilbert barbier le seuil
qui retenu par cet amendement 280 qui
avait été imaginé et rédigé par joël
cardo et de 20 salariés
et là on est vraiment dans la tpe je
pense que la pénibilité est en effet une
nécessité
la réflexion sur la pénibilité est un
devoir absolu mais je pense profondément
que notre système ne peut pas
fonctionner dans des petites entreprises
sauf
à générer des charges administratives qu
à aucun moment vous ne faites l'effort
d'évaluer rapporté au nombre de salariés
si nous avons parce que madame demontès
vous avez dit quelque chose d'important
tout à l'heure dans un autre sur un
autre article du 10 mai on passe de la
sécurité sociale au droit du travail
on passe de l'invalidité à la pénibilité
c'est à dire qu'on revient au coeur de
l'entreprise
on est plus sur le terrain de la santé
je cherchais du regard mon collègue
alain milon mais plus longue sur le
terrain de la santé on est sur le
terrain du fonctionnement de
l'entreprise alors dans le
fonctionnement de l'entreprise ou bien
on a retient des normes générales qui
s'applique d'une façon d'errer
indifférenciée à des grandes catégories
d'entreprises ou bien comme le jeu le
propose la loi à travers des fiches on
entre dans le détail de l'activité de
chaque salarié
je crains que ce soit à peu près
irréaliste parce que il y à une
prévisibilité théorique de
l'intervention du salarié lorsqu'il va
réparer une chaudière livré d'immeubles
en ville ou monter un mur d'agglos on
peut l'imaginer simplement la vie ça se
passe pas toujours comme ça il ya des
moments où le salarié est obligé de
s'adapter
l'équipe le contremaître s'adapte aux
réalités du travail et ce qui était
facile devient difficile on a évoqué l'
usage du marteau piqueur observé démolir
une dalle dont on s'aperçoit finalement
qu'elle est en béton armé avec un
ferraillage danse c'est un travail
beaucoup beaucoup plus difficile qui est
imprévisible comment va-t-on procédé va
considérer que chaque mètre carré de
terrassement vos permet d'atteindre un
seuil de pénibilité où il me faudra
revenir sur chaque action très
honnêtement on a besoin de comprendre
alors vous allez me dire ces réflexions
sont du niveau de l'application n'aime
pas des décrets des circulaires je le
concède mais ce que je vous
les dires à travers cet amendement c'est
que très tranquillement vous coller une
charge nouvelle qui représente en terme
de travail vous savez que dans une année
un salarié doit je crois en moyenne 220
journée de travail à son employeur et
l'employeur lui doit à son entreprise
365 jours par an at il envie
nécessairement de consacrer son temps
disponible non pas appliquer des lois
savez vous êtes tout à fait raison il
faut appliquer des lois non pas
appliquer des normes parce qu'il faut en
effet les appliquer des normes de
sécurité les normes d'hygiène des normes
d'environnement
donc on accepte tout cela mais lorsqu'il
faudra qu'ils établissent une sorte de
dialogue permanent prévisionnel d'abord
et ensuite rétrospectif pour savoir si
toutes les marches d'accès au seuil de
pénibilité ont été franchies ou non je
crains que vous arriviez un véritable
découragement des employeurs qui risque
pour les toutes petites entreprises de
prendre la décision de ne pas saisir les
opportunités de développement
lorsqu'elles existent tant ils seront
préoccupés de lors de la charge de
travail que représentera que
représenterait je m inconditionnels ne
pas être systématiquement négatif que
représenterait une interprétations
conflictuelles de l'obligation d'établir
des fiches qui restitue la réalité de la
pénibilité dans le travail s'il s'agit
d'une norme générale bon ben on coche
des cases
s'il s'agit de retirer ce titre est ce
qu a été la réalité du journée de
travail sur un chantier
bonjour les dégâts en tous les cas
bonjour dégagement pour l'employeur
c'est la raison pour laquelle je voulais
défendre avec conviction cet amendement
280 pour les moins de 20 salariés
merci monsieur longuet y at il d'autres
demandes de parole je n'en vois pas je
vais mettre l'amendement 281 présenté
par un magnum de roche ou voire deux
avis défavorables qui est pour
merci qui est contre
merci mes chers collègues d'abstention
et n'est pas adopté nous passons à
l'amendement 161 qui le présente
la présidente david merci madame la
présidente la maman que nous vous
proposons ici visite vise à tirer les
conclusions de l'allongement progressif
de la durée de vie au travail
nous considérons en effet qu'étendre le
nombre d'années de cotisations quand
bien même l'espérance de vie augmente
n'est pas sans conséquences sur la santé
des travailleurs
encore aujourd'hui dans nombre de
métiers pénibles les conséquences d'une
vie de travail sont telles que
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé est
très inégal et que bien souvent ce sont
les populations issues du milieu déjà
frappée par la crise et les bas salaires
qui sont précisément les plus mal lotis
soyons clairs la retraite à 60 ans ne
sera bientôt avec ses multiples réformes
cannes souvenirs nombre de nos jeunes ne
peuvent aujourd'hui espérer compte tenu
des périodes de chômage ou d'inactivité
de retraite complète avant d'atteindre
65 ans aussi
nous devons réfléchir sur les conditions
dans lesquelles les citoyennes et
citoyens de ce pays auront à effectuer
ces années supplémentaires nous
considérons donc qu'il est tout à fait
opportun de renforcer les protections du
travailleur dans le domaine de la santé
au travail car c'est précisément cet
aspect qui sera le plus touché par
l'allongement de la durée de cotisation
et partant de la durée de vie passée au
travail notre amendement vise donc
clairement à ce que les prescriptions du
médecin du travail soient suivies
d'effets merci madame la présidente
david l'avis de la commission madame le
rapporteur oui madame la présidente
madame la ministre
chers collègues votre amendement porte
sur le renforcement des obligations de
l'employeur envers les prescriptions du
médecin du travail
bien évidemment je pense que sur ses
bancs en particulier nous sommes bien
évidemment d'accord avec ses obligations
de l'employeur pour autant madame david
cet amendement n'a pas de lien
particulier avec l'objet du projet de
loi
on peut même dire qu'il s'agit d'un
cavalier législatif
la jurisprudence du conseil
constitutionnel sur ce point est très
clair je vous rappelle qu'il avait
censuré la réforme de la médecine du
travail introduite dans la loi de 2010
au cours de la navette parlementaire
donc c'est un avis défavorable de la
commission sur cet amendement
merci madame le rapporteur madame la
ministre oui mais même avis bien
évidemment il y à un risque reste plus
qu'à un risque d'inconstitutionnalité au
demeurant j'ajoute madame la sénatrice
que les dispositions que vous souhaitez
introduire sont déjà prévues par
d'autres dispositions du code du travail
et donc qui prévoit l'obligation pour
l'employeur de prendre en considération
les propositions du médecin du travail
est de motiver son refus sont à
dispositions des articles 46 24 m elle
parle en 46 24-3 et l 46 24-1 du code du
travail donc sans que vous pourriez
retirer votre amendement sinon je te
donne un avis défavorable
merci madame la ministre madame david
vous êtes sollicité pour un autre est
maintenant très bien je lui mets donc au
monsieur longuet oui madame la
présidente madame le ministre
non cet amendement est intéressant il
est très intéressant parce que il nous
replonge dans le débat que nous avons eu
hier soir sur le rôle du médecin du
travail et je crois me souvenir de
mémoire mais on peut se tromper les
amendements sont nombreux que nous avons
adopté un amendement demandant
permettant la consultation du médecin du
travail pour l'établissement des fiches
de pénibilité dans l'entreprise contre
l'avis d'ailleurs du gouvernement et du
rapporteur et à partir du moment où on
rit on a réintroduit le médecin hier
je comprends que madame
david veuille réintroduire le médecin
aujourd'hui
bon maintenant il ya le risque ce risque
qui serait dissipée madame le mi6 nous
étions dans une procédure normale
il y aurait une navette avec le temps
dans avec le temps c'est pas l'éternité
avec quinze jours avec trois semaines on
prend le on a la possibilité de
consulter les meilleurs juristes et
d'éviter la perspective honteuse une
censure par le conseil constitutionnel
et comme on travaille à marche forcée au
tambour je dirais eh bien on n'a pas le
temps d'entrer dans un détail qui n'est
pas un détail qui est quand même très
important parce que si on va se
contredire nous réintroduisant le
médecin hier et cet avis du médecin
n'est plus sanctionnés aujourd'hui j'ai
bien compris madame le ministre que vous
le l'avis du médecin peut être
sanctionnée à un autre titre mais
justement je reviens sur les
observations de madame demontès au titre
de la santé paho titre de la pénibilité
et c'est exactement ce que nous voulions
ferrière ses maîtres le médecin du
travail dans la pénibilité sans pour
autant mettre la pénibilité dans la
santé du dans la médecine du travail
bon enfin tout ça pour dire qu'on ne
participera pas ce vote parce que c'est
vraiment une affaire interne à la
majorité gouvernementale
merci monsieur longuet y at il d'autres
demandes de parole devient madame david
oui merci madame la présidente j'ai bien
entendu est effectivement et
l'inconstitutionnalité possible et
l'article du code du travail qui déjà
prévoit que les prescriptions faites à
l'employeur par le médecin sont en
licence opposable sauf que nous savons
toutes et tous ici que bien que cette
obligation soit déjà dans le code du
travail elles ne sont pas tout à fait
respecté ça se saurait si dans
l'entreprise lorsqu'un médecin du
travail demande quelque chose se soit
réellement appliquée donc nous ce que
nous demandons puisqu'il y a là un
nouveau chapitre nouveau il y a
cette pénibilité nouvelle qui est inclus
dans le code du travail
et bien que dans ce chapitre on puisse
aussi demandé au médecin du travail ce
qui leur à l'employeur pardon à ce
qu'ils respectent les prescriptions du
médecin du travail aujourd'hui dans
l'aujourd'hui des choses ne sont pas
appliquées madame la ministre il faut
bien que nous le disions et jeu donc
nous maintenant cet amendement parce
qu'il me semble important que dans ce
chapitre là concernant la pénibilité et
concernant le médecin du travail que ce
soit précisé dans le texte que les
prescriptions du médecin soit rendue
opposable à l'employeur
merci madame la présidente david
d'autres demandes de parole je mets donc
on voit cet amendement 161 présenté par
madame david qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables qui est pour merci qui est
contre merci mes chers collègues
abstentions il n'est pas adopté nous
arrivons le moment 162 qui le présente
monsieur lapin mcqueen pour poursuivre
dans notre volonté de mieux prendre en
compte la pénibilité au travail et de
défendre les droits des salariés
nous proposons avec cet amendement de
modifier un article du code du travail
en l'occurrence l'article l 46 24-3 en
effet comme le stipule le code lorsque
le médecin du travail est saisi par un
employeur pour éviter toute altération
de la santé des travailleurs du fait de
lors de leur travail notamment
surveillant leurs conditions d'hygiène
les risques de contagion et leur état de
santé tout ça sur leur lieu de travail
fait connaître ses propositions par
écrit ses propositions ainsi que la
réponse de l'employeur sont tenues à
leurs demandes à la disposition du
comité d'hygiène de sécurité et des
conditions de travail ou à défaut des
délégués du personnel de l'inspecteur ou
du contrôleur du travail du médecin
inspecteur du travail des agents des
services de présence de prévention des
organismes de sécurité sociale
nous proposons de supprimer les termes à
leurs demandes afin que ces propositions
soient tenus de façon systématique à
disposition des personnes précitées le
caractère systématique permettra plus de
transparence et de réactivité pour
prendre les mesures nécessaires à même
de garantir une bonne santé aux salariés
cette mesure est simple elle nous paraît
de bon sens et permet de répondre à
l'objectif affirmé dans l'article 1 de
ce même projet de loi si l'espérance de
vie a bel et bien été augmenté et que
l'on recule de fait l'âge légal de
départ à la retraite en
mentant la durée de cotisation comme le
souhaite le gouvernement
il paraît à minima indispensable de
s'assurer que les salariés arrivent en
bonne santé au moment de la retraite
le rôle du médecin du travail ainsi que
les recommandations qu'il peut faire
sont en ce sens essentiel c'est le
prolongement de notre débat d'hier
et si madame cohen l'avis de la
commission madame le rapporteur madame
la présidente madame la ministre madame
cohen qui avait présenté cet amendement
qui prévoit l'accès direct du chsct aux
propositions des préconisations faites
par le médecin du travail ainsi qu'à la
réponse formulée par l'employeur cet
amendement comme le précédent et est un
cavalier concernant la médecine du
travail c'est donc un même avis de la
part de la commission un avis
défavorable
merci avis défavorable merci madame la
ministre monsieur longuet oui on très
simplement je crains madame quand même
que votre amendement desservent la cause
que vous les déforme parce que si on
arrose tout le monde il ne lirons plus
les documents
le ch s'était lui saisira
l'employeur et il est au coeur de les
dispositifs et s'il ya vraiment un
contentieux
il mobilisera les partenaires dont il a
besoin si au contraire vous diffuser
chaque chaque document vous risquez
d'avoir un phénomène de saturation c'est
une observation de bon sens qui nous
conduira à soutenir une cette fois ci le
gouvernement et le rapporteur et il y at
il d'autres demandes de parole je n'en
vois pas donc je vais mettre aux voix
l'amendement 162 présenté par madame
cohen qui a reçu deux avis défavorables
qui éprouvent merci contre merci mes
chers collègues l'abstention il n'est
pas l'adopter
la maman 164 est défendu par monsieur
watrin oui nous avions déjà déposé cet
amendement lors de l'examen de la
proposition de loi relative à
l'organisation de la médecine du travail
en janvier 2011
il n'avait malheureusement pas été
retenu par la majorité de l'époque ni
par le gouvernement
il nous semblait nous semble toujours
important de compléter le code du
travail est bon si c'est déjà dans le
code du travail qu'on nous cite
l'article
et de préciser qu'en cas de contentieux
lié à l'altération à la dégradation de
l'état de santé du salarié en lien avec
son activité professionnelle
le refus de l'employeur de se conformer
aux prescriptions du médecin lui est
opposable
en effet conformément à l'article l 4121
1 du code du travail l'employeur prend
les mesures nécessaires pour assurer la
sécurité et protéger la santé physique
et mentale des travailleurs
fin de citation c'est dire que pèsent
sur lui non seulement une obligation de
moyens mais aussi une obligation de
résultat telle est leur jurisprudence
constante depuis l'arrêt rendu par la
chambre sociale de la cour de cassation
le 28 février 2006 dans la sphère saq
beat france technologie qui consacre à
ce principe en ces termes je cite
l'employeur tenu d'une obligation de
sécurité de résultat en matière de
protection de la santé la sécurité des
travailleurs dans l'entreprise
doit en assurer l'effectivité fin de
citation il résulte de cette situation
de droit que l'employeur doit garantir à
chaque travailleur le résultat attendu
c'est à dire la protection de sa santé
au travail
en cas de défaut de résultats c'est à
dire de dégradation de la santé causés
par le travail même seulement parties
l'employeur est présumé responsable
d'une défaillance fautifs les
dispositions de cet amendement
s'inscrivent dans cette logique nous
entendons donner force obligatoire aux
interventions prescrite par le médecin
du travail afin d'éviter que celles ci
restent vaines et c'est souvent ce que
l'on constate malheureusement dans les
entreprises rien ne sert en effet de
confier cette faculté aux médecins du
travail si l'employeur peut
systématiquement et sans formalité
particulière s'y soustraire nous
proposons donc le refus de l'employeur
de se conformer aux prescriptions doit
être motivé par écrit
chacun l'aura compris cette précision
vise en cas de contentieux a facilité la
preuve du manquement caractérisé de
l'employeur en l'espèce par son récent
refus de suivre les prescriptions
formulées par le médecin du travail
je vous remercie chers collègues l'avis
de la commission van damme le rapporteur
sur cet amendement 164 madame la
présidente c'est la même analyse que
nous faisons au niveau de la commission
c'est à dire c'est un cavalier et donc
nous
mais ce émettant un avis défavorable
s'imagine oui mais ma vie madame la
présidente j'ajoute que évidemment en
cas de contentieux le refus de
l'employeur de consulter ou de tenir
compte des préconisations du médecin du
travail lui serait est opposable c'est
l'état du droit actuel donc à vis des
favoris mais rssi madame la ministre
madame lambda je voulais simplement
soutenir de façon circonstanciée la
proposition de nos collègues en prenant
l'exemple très actuelle que chacun
connaît sur son territoire des chantiers
de désamiantage l'obligation de résultat
et d'effectivité de la protection de la
santé des travailleurs est
particulièrement sensible dans ce
domaine ce sont des chantiers itinérant
ce sont souvent des mains d'oeuvres non
durables et qu'ils ne sont eux qui
signent l'obligation de connaissance de
la dangerosité du produit et qui ne sont
même pas francophone il n'y a qu'à
collecter auprès de l'inspection du
travail ses bordereaux dont on recense
beaucoup plus de signatures par crois
que de signature par réellement un
paraphe
en conséquence si nous adoptions et je
le souhaite
la proposition de nos collègues nous
enverrions un signal extrêmement fort et
quand madame la ministre dit mais s'il y
avait du contentieux
évidemment que la parole du médecin du
travail ferait foi pour que
l'entrepreneur soit mis en situation de
responsabilité
c'est fort vrai mais nous ne poursuivons
pas de futur coupable éventuelles nous
poursuivons le bon état de santé des
travailleurs et en inscrivant sa dans
nos textes maintenant nous éviterions
les morts à venir de l'amiante qui sont
en train de se reconstituer
à l'occasion des très nombreux chantiers
de désamiantage même lendemain la parole
et agent de stars
oui madame la présidente c'était pour
exprimer mon désaccord avec le mot
cavaliers en disant que c'est un
amendement cavaliers puisque si l'on
prend l'article l
4624 3 qui est citée par l'amendement
lorsque le médecin du travail constate
la présence d'un risque pour la santé
des travailleurs
il propose par les cris motivé et
circonstancié des mesures visant à la
préserver ensuite il ya quelques années
à qui nous précise et la part
l'amendement 164 il précise justement
les conditions
en quoi ce n'est pas un cavalier dans le
sens que nous avons dit à plusieurs
reprises que il fallait pas qu'il y ait
des points de pénibilité pour pour
gagner du temps de retraite en gros 1
depuis le début donc on a toujours parlé
qu' il fallait qu'il y ait une
prévention de la pénibilité que
justement il fallait que la santé des
travailleurs soient préservés à chaque
fois cela a été dit donc on peut pas
dire que l'amendement est complètement
en dehors des débats que nous avons
depuis quelques jours alors pour donc
non seulement il ya un bien fondé de cet
amendement mais il s'inscrit dans la
continuité des débats que nous avons eus
depuis le début de l'examen de ce projet
de loi donc vous l'aurez compris marie
christine blandin l'ayant dix mois
l'heureux dix ans nous soutenons
l'amendement proposé par nos collègues
je vous remercie monsieur caezar la
parole et agen a relogé
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai écouté
très attentivement cet amendement
présenté par notre collègue du groupe
communiste et au fond les la situation
c'est clair hier nous avons demandé et
cela nous avons soutenu et donc demandé
que les médecins ce de l'entreprise
médecin du travail soit associé à
l'élaboration des fiches de pénibilité
pour autant et j'ai bien écouté madame
le rapporteur aux idées du bunker de bon
coeur et jeune homme pourquoi parce que
un médecin dans l'entreprise est en
mesure d'observer la pénibilité d'une
tâche est capable et c'est là où je
voulais en venir de distinguer ce qui
est de la pénibilité et de ce qui est de
l'atteinte à la santé ce qui n'est pas
la même chose car et je reviens sur les
observations de madame de montèze
lorsqu'elle me disais mais cet article 8
est très important on passe du code
sécurisation le code du travail
vous avez raison je vous donne acte je
crois que c'est fort c'est clair car
pour reprendre une formule simple tout
ce qui est dangereux n'est pas
nécessairement pénible le tabac par
exemple est dangereux mais la plupart de
ceux qui fument le font par plaisir
donc on peut faire des choses
dangereuses sans pour autant qu'elle
soit pénible
on peut dire de la même chose de
l'alcool d'ailleurs le col est plutôt
agréable mais c'est profondément
dangereux et chacun le sait oui c'est
surtout pénible pour les autres pour
vous dire les vérités charles collègues
enfin bon et puis il y a des choses qui
en revanche sont parfaitement pénible
par exemple l'écouté quand on veut faire
aboutir un texte rapidement mais ce
n'est absolument pas dangereux de
m'écouter il n'y a pas d'atteinte à la
santé ni d'atteintes graves en tous les
cas il ya même parfois l'éveil les vues
l'éveil d'une réflexion et d'une
ouverture
donc il faut bien séparer ce qui est
pénible et ce qui est dangereux et
d'ailleurs vous avez utilisé la formule
altération et dégradation de la santé
je serais intéressé de savoir quelle est
la différence entre l'altération et la
dégradation mais ça c'est de la
sémantique on peut laisser un débat de
commissions revenons à l'essentiel je
crois que vous avez tout à fait raison
madame le rapporteur distinguons ce qui
relève de la santé et qui devra être
traité pour consolider ce travail de
prévention du médecin du travail dans
l'entreprise de la pénibilité qui
a pas vocation à déboucher sur une
altération et dégradation de la santé
parce que sinon à ce moment on n'est
plus dans la pénibilité on est dans
l'incapacité on est dans le la
dégradation physique on peut faire des
choses qui soit pénible sans qu'elles
soient nécessairement dangereuse c'est
ce que je voulais dire et c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous ne
soutiendrons pas les amendements nos
collègues communistes qui mérite un
débat et dans d'autres circonstances
mais la parole la parole et à notre
collègue sylvain runberg oui madame la
présidente madame ministre mes chers
collègues je crois que en fin de compte
on peut être tous d'accord sur
l'amendement tel qu'il est là rédigés
le problème c'est de savoir s'il est
bien située là où le place dans le texte
est-ce qui va véritablement vocation à
figurer dans le texte
c'est évident que je ne peux que
souscrire à ce qu'a dit marie-christine
blandin en prenant l'exemple de
l'amiante
évidemment que nous connaissons bien
parce que il est normal de mon point de
vue que si un médecin du travail
dieu sait si mal mais malheureusement
dans le domaine de l'amiante ya eu
parfois des manquements que l'employeur
se conforme à ce que dit le médecin du
travail si ça remarqué est grave et
engage véritable en altère la santé du
salarié mais est-ce que ça doit figurer
ici
cette opposition de le caractère
opposable plutôt de cette prescription
je ne le crois pas donc pour la même
raison que monsieur longuet nous nous
abstiendrons merci sa collègue
y at il d'autres demandes de parole je
suis un train
oui simplement de deux remarques c'est
pour dire ce dispositif voit qu'il n'ya
pas de divergence de fond avec le groupe
de la majorité les autres groupes de la
majorité sénatoriale puisque nous
l'avions ensemble proposé soutenue en
janvier 2011 alors après la question de
forme
bon on peut toujours se poser des
questions et se compliquer la vie moi
j'ai vu bien des cavaliers passé j'ai
peu d'expérience sénatoriales peux vous
dire j'en ai vu il ya pas si longtemps
des cavaliers beaucoup beaucoup plus
évident celui là n'est pas évident pour
la raison qu'a rappelé monsieur décès ça
je remercie d'avoir citer le texte du
code de travail donc clairement ce n'est
pas avec le cavalier puisqu'ils se
rattache précisément à l'article mais
aussi je pense qu'on est dans le sens
même de ce que nous voulons tous ici sur
tous les bancs c'est ce que j'ai bien
entendu sur tous les bancs lee dire
qu'il fallait renforcer le volet
préventif de ceux de ce dispositif et
bien nous sommes dans la prévention ici
et c'est pourquoi je tenais à rappeler
que normalement nous devrions tous voté
cet amendement
merci monsieur watrin plus de demandes
de parole je mets donc aux voix
l'amendement 164 présentée par monsieur
watrin deux avis défavorables qui est
pour voter cet amendement
merci qui est contre
abstention n'est pas adopté l'amendement
163 qui le présente monsieur le
scouarnec
merci main présidente dans la mine is
much à coller le souhaitez avec cet
amendement revenir sur une disposition à
laquelle nous nous étions opposés en
2011 avec nos collègues socialise la
commission des affaires sociales lorsque
nous étions dans l'opposition moi
j'étais pas là mais si une aussi unit et
j'ai fait là déjà le début au moment de
l'examen du texte relatif à
l'organisation de la médecine du travail
c'est en effet ce texte a permis pour
certaines professions
les artistes et techniciens
intermittents du spectacle les
mannequins les salariés du particulier
employeur et les vrp que des accords de
branche puisse déroger au droit commun
de la protection de la santé au travail
des salariés aux motifs cote est stable
selon nous que l'activité
professionnelle des salariés en question
les écarte déjà de la médecine du
travail
ainsi cette réforme prévoit que des
messages généralistes puissent accomplir
des actes et des missions qui relèvent
normalement démission et compétents des
médecins du travail
or il s'agit justement de salariés qui
de par leurs activités professionnelles
peuvent se trouver isolées ou
confrontées à des difficultés sanitaires
certaine en raison notamment du
morcellement de leurs horaires dans le
cas des mannequins par exemple collègue
jean pierre godefroy avait développé le
phénomène de l'anorexie si l'on prend le
cas des vrp ces salariés sont soumis à
des contraintes importantes culture du
résultat rémunération variable autonomie
non contre les pressions multiples des
clients et les dirigeants au point qu il
figure aujourd'hui parmi les dix
premières victimes de ce qu'il est
convenu d'appeler les troubles
psychosociaux
il en va de même pour les intermittents
du spectacle qui compte parmi les
salariés les plus précaires les priver
de l'accès à la médecine du travail au
motif que leur précarité rend difficile
les rencontres régulières avec les
équipes pluridisciplinaires n'est pas
sérieux au regard des enjeux de santé
publique
ces salariés devraient pouvoir accéder
comme les autres
la médecine du travail or le dispositif
qui a dû adopter en 2011 prenait
prétexte de ce que leur suivi médical
est trop difficile ou trop espacés pour
les ans des cartes et c'est pourquoi
nous souhaitons avec cet amendement
apporté des garanties suffisantes à la
préservation de la santé de ces
professionnels soumis à des conditions
de travail particulières il est donc
proposé que l'habilitation des médecins
non spécialisés ne puisse résulter que
d'une autorisation délivrée par une
autorité administrative compétente en
matière de santé publique et non un
simple protocole de gré à gré entre
médecins non spécialisés et le service
de santé au travail
je vous remercie merci monsieur le
scouarnec l'avis de la commission m la
rapporteure madame la présidente madame
la ministre mon cher collègue
même analyse de la commission cet
amendement n'est pas à sa place dans ce
projet de loi donc c'est un même avis
qui est un avis défavorable
merci madame la ministre oui mais ma vie
madame la présidente monsieur désessard
si vous permettez je vous dirais que
vous avez une conception des cavaliers
assez cavalière parce que franchement il
suffit pas il ne suffit pas d'introduire
dans un texte la référence à un autre
texte pour que et d'ensuite broder
autour pour que ça suffise à établir un
lien 10 aux dents dans le cadre d'un
projet de loi donne et je me permets de
vous rappeler qu'en 2010 le conseil
constitutionnel a annulé de très
nombreuses article qui avait été
introduit et qui portait sur la médecine
du travail donc là nous ne parlons pas
de choses abstraites c'est en 2010 dans
le projet de loi de la précédente
majorité des disposition avait été
introduite sur la médecine du travail
quand été annulés merci madame on
merci madame la ministre madame eugénie
son oui merci madame la présidente
j'entends bien les arguments de madame
la rapporteure elle me donne la ministre
indiquant qu' un certain nombre d
amendements concernant le sujet de
l'organisation de la médecine du travail
étaient ces amendements étaient des
cavaliers mais je voudrais dire que par
ailleurs ces amendements étaient par
ailleurs tout à fait intéressant et il
signe l'importance de revenir sur le
sujet de l'organisation de la médecine
du travail et d'une nouvelle réforme de
la médecine du travail qui soit vraiment
protectrice de la santé au travail
je le dis à propos de cet amendement
parce que vous nos collègues du groupe
src évoque la nécessité pour le médecin
du travail de ne pas être en même temps
le médecin
le médecin de soins du salarié ou de
l'employeur
c'est fondamental c'est fondamental et
savait d'ailleurs été inscrits dans la
loi permettant la réforme de sécurité
sociale en 2004 loi qui instaurerait la
mise en place du dossier médical
personnalisé et il y avait deux
circonstances dans lesquelles le dossier
médical personnalisé ne pouvait être
transmis à un autre médecin
c'était quand ce médecin était un
médecin du travail ou quand ce médecin
était un médecin d'assurance donc tout
ça pour se dit pour dire que bien
évidemment j'entends les arguments qui a
dit que les différents amendements que
nous examinons sont des cavaliers mais
vraiment le l'urgence de la réforme de
la médecine du travail doit être entendu
merci mr et mme génisson
y at il d'autres demandes de parole sur
cet amendement je n'en vois pas je vais
donc le mettre aux voix c'est
l'amendement présenté par monsieur le
scouarnec qui a reçu deux avis
défavorables qui est pour voter cet
amendement
merci qui est contre merci abstention et
n'est pas adopté l'amendement 165 et
présenté par alain pasquet
merci madame la présidente madame le
ministre mes chers collègues
cet amendement vise à renforcer les
obligations en matière de santé au
travail pour les entreprises
s'il existe des sanctions des amendes
pour les dirigeants d'entreprise ne
respectant pas ses obligations
nous considérons qu'il est nécessaire de
compléter cet arsenal de sanctions
c'est un fait nombre d'entreprises ne
respectent pas leurs obligations
qu'il s'agisse de visite médicale
obligatoire au minimum tous les deux ans
ou d'un service de santé au travail dans
de nombreux cas les entreprises visées
par les enquêtes des services de
l'inspection du travail arguant de
difficultés économiques difficultés
qu'ils empêcheraient de tenir leurs
engagements en tant qu'employeur
pourtant la question de la santé au
travail et nous l'avons dit à plusieurs
reprises capitale
il ne serait hélas loi est d'ailleurs
clair là dessus et y avoir à discuter
sur ces questions un salarié en bonne
santé
c'est une entreprise en bonne santé
certes dans l'esprit général ces
dispositions concernent surtout les
métiers considérés comme les plus
exposés
il est évident que le secteur industriel
ne peut pas fonctionner sans des
salariés en bonne santé mais cela est
également vrai pour tous les secteurs
en réalité la prévalence grandissante
des troubles musculo squelettiques et
bien une preuve de l'actualité de la
médecine du travail dans tous les
domaines d'activité ce sont aujourd'hui
près de 40000 personnes indemnisées par
année pour sans doute encore plus de cas
non déclarés et c'est trouve dans de
vrais répercussions économiques puisque
ces indemnisations équivalent à plus de
800 millions d'euros couvrant près de 8
millions d'heures de travail perdues une
réalité grandissante qui doit donc nous
inciter à renforcer la médecine du
travail qui permet précisément de
repérer ces troubles de les prévenir et
ainsi d'assurer la pérennité de
l'activité économique
ce que nous proposons donc encore une
fois c'est d'inscrire dans la loi
l'obligation sous peine d'une cotisation
supplémentaire du respect absolu des
obligations de l'employeur en matière de
santé au travail
cette sanction est dessinée
ne pas être perçu évidemment l'effet
recherché est un dissuasif
cette mesure permettrait ainsi de mettre
les employeurs en face de leurs
responsabilités alors même que les
contentieux le montre la loi a encore du
mal à être respecté par tous merci n'a
même pas ce qu'est la vie de la
commission madame le rapporteur oui
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues
cet amendement propose d'affranchir
d'injonction préalable imposition à
l'employeur par la carsat d'une
cotisation supplémentaire s'il ne
respecte pas ses obligations en matière
d'organisation des services de santé au
travail comme les quatre précédents
amendement cet amendement aurait sans
doute toute sa place dans un texte
réformant la médecine du travail
il n'a pas de plus il n'a pas sa place
dans ce projet de loi c'est donc un avis
défavorable de la commission
merci madame le rapporteur madame la
ministre
oui avis défavorable je voudrais
rebondir sur ce que disait tout à
l'heure
catherine génisson je crois que madame
un rapporteur l'a souligné elle même de
façon extrêmement clair il ne s'agit pas
en donnant un avis défavorable à ces
amendements de se prononcer de façon
négative sur le rôle la place de la
médecine du travail et je crois qu'ici
nous partageons tous le sentiment que
cette médecine du travail ne fonctionne
pas aussi bien qu'elle devrait
fonctionner qu elle pourrait fonctionner
qu'à évidence des améliorations doivent
être apportées qui porte aussi bien sur
le fond des politiques de santé publique
à mettre en avant que en termes
d'organisation du service même de la
médecine du travail c'est ainsi que pour
ce qui est du fond des politiques
publiques g - en tant que ministre de la
santé enfin en charge de la santé
annoncé que la stratégie nationale de
santé devait permettre une meilleure
coordination des actions de santé
publique dans l'ensemble des domaines
d'action publique c'est à dire aussi
bien pour ce qui relève directement du
ministère en charge de la santé que pour
les enfants dans le cadre de l'éducation
nationale
pour les salariés dans le cadre de la
médecine du travail alors que
indépendamment du rap du rattachement
administratif qui peut être qu'ils aient
fait des services en question
et puis sur le plan de l'organisation
même de cette médecine du travail de
médecine du travail je veux rappeler que
le ministre chargé du travail michel
sapin a pris l'engagement devant le
conseil d'orientation sur les conditions
de travail qu'il a présidée il y a que
le 14 mai dernier qu'il a pris
l'engagement de présenter un bilan de la
mise en oeuvre de la réforme de la
médecine du travail des services de
santé au travail en associant le copte
pour identifier les points qui mérite
d'être amélioré et d'ailleurs dans le
cas de la grande conférence sociale des
20 et 21 juin dernier
des réflexions ont été d'ores et déjà
engagé sur ce terrain là donc la
question de l'avenir de la médecine du
travail de la réorg et de sa
réorganisation et de comment dire de 2,2
dans l'outillage de cette médecine du
travail pour mieux prendre en compte les
situations des salariés dans le monde du
travail
ces questions là elles sont sur le
devant de l'agenda ou dans l'agenda
gouvernemental et elles sont tout à fait
prioritaire pour nous même si nous ne
pouvons pas considérer que des mesures
concernant la médecine du travail ont
leur place dans ce texte
merci madame la ministre pour ces
précisions
l'un parce que oui je crois qu'on a bien
compris
le problème enfin que vous pouvez voir
au travers des amendements que nous
avons déposés qui pour vous non pas leur
place dans ce texte
si vous voulez nous il nous semble que
la médecine du travail dans le cadre de
la mise en oeuvre de comptes pénibilité
a un rôle important à jouer et nous
semblait intéressant de pouvoir en
débattre dans le ce texte là dans le
cadre de la réforme des retraites
puisque c'est là que nous abordons la
question du conte pénibilité et ma foi
données et montrer qu'elle peut être le
rôle de la médecine du travail et c'est
la raison pour laquelle nous avons
proposé un certain nombre
d'améliorations mais ça n'enlève rien au
débat un an des vies qu'on aura sur la
réforme de la médecine du travail qui
est qui est prévu et un gage et y
compris avec les partenaires sociaux
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle je
maintiens l'amendement qui pour le
groupe crc
nous considérons pas que ce sont ceux
sont des cavaliers ce qui est je le mets
donc aux voix il a reçu à monsieur bah
merci madame la présidente je n'ai pas
voulu abuser de la parole et donc je
m'exprime sur l'ensemble des questions
touchant à la médecine du travail à
propos de cet amendement numéro 163
alors même que je n'ai pas pris la
parole sur l'amendement numéro 165
je voudrais remercier madame la ministre
d'avoir souligné que dans le domaine de
la médecine du travail
des évolutions sont nécessaires elles
sont même je crois indispensable et le
motif de notre opposition à ces deux
amendements n'est pas principalement le
fait qu'il s'agisse de cavaliers même si
nous partageons la conviction qui a été
énoncé par madame le rapporteur et
madame la ministre sur le fait
qu'effectivement ces amendements n'ont
qu'un lien assez distendus avec ce qui
est l'objet principal de ce texte
portant diverses dispositions relatives
aux retraites
voilà c'est le fond qui prime est
évidemment mais de ce point de vue
madame ministre j'ai une petite
déception en ce qui concerne le contenu
de votre réponse parce que elles
n'éclairent guerre notre assemblée sur
les intentions du gouvernement en ce qui
concerne les révéler les réformes
éventuelles à venir en matière de
médecine de travail je crois que l'ue
était appréciable pour pour
l'information du sénat que vous nous en
disiez un peu plus long je précise mon
attente
je trouve pour ma part qu'aucun de ces
deux amendements ne va dans la bonne
direction
tout d'abord parce que il me semble que
vouloir ériger des barrières
supplémentaires au recours par défaut à
des médecins généralistes
quand il n'y a pas de médecins du
travail comporte un risque grave celui
tout simplement de baisser la garde et
qu'il n'y ait plus de médecins du tout
en assumant cette fonction de médecin du
travail dans un certain nombre
d'entreprises et par conséquent nous
sommes devant un dilemme qu'il est très
difficile de trancher bien sûr surtout
nos bancs nous reconnaissons la
nécessité d'une formation et d'une
habilitation spécifique pour les
médecins du travail
mais pour autant quand la réalité
constatée nous montrent que nous n'avons
pas suffisamment de médecins du travail
il ne suffit pas de poser de nouvelles
règles en disant pas de dérogation il
faut absolument une habilitation pour
que ça règle le problème démographique
de la médecine du travail
et puis il ya le second point cet
amendement dont nous débattons
alors là je dois dire que je ne suis pas
du tout surpris par la méthode utilisée
par
les membres du groupe communiste
républicain et citoyen pour tenter de
régler les problèmes
c'est la méthode unique le prélèvement
supplémentaire la pénalité et de
préférence de prélèvement et la pénalité
pesant sur les entreprises et donc c'est
la politique du tout fiscale alors moi
je vous dis tout simplement que cette
réponse n'est pas pertinente elle ne
peut en rien réglé les problèmes et
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous nous
opposons à cette à cet amendement
si monsieur va madame génisson merci
madame la présidente
non une une réaction très rapide sur à
la suite des propos de notre collègue
monsieur bah il n'est pas question de
dire d'abord de mettre en cause ni les
médecins du travail
ni les médecins généralistes et n'est
pas question non plus de dire qu'un
médecin généraliste ne pourrait pas sous
certaines conditions de validation de
connaissances qu'ils pourraient avoir à
acquérir en matière de médecine du
travail qu'ils ne puissent exercer cette
compétence ce qui est important c'est
qu'un médecin qui est que le médecin
traitant du salarié ou de l'employeur
n'est pas de lien les aucun lien avec le
médecin du travail de ce même salarié ou
de ce même travailleur ou énorme et
c'est très important que de le dire
merci madame génisson
y at il d'autres demandes de parole sur
cet amendement
madame de roche merci madame la
présidente
simplement pour rebondir un peu aussi ce
qui a été dit sur cette médecine du
travail
il est vrai qu'ils font des formes de
médecine du travail et peut-être
compléter celle de celle qui a pu être
fait auparavant mais ça a été dit par
philippa les gros problèmes sont des
problèmes de démographie médicale et
existe déjà en matière de médecine
générale
ils sont encore plus prégnant en matière
de médecine du travail et même si on
élargit à des adieux pluridisciplinaire
on rencontre sur nous mêmes difficultés
alors l'amendement du groupe crc vise en
effet à pointer les failles qui peuvent
exister dans certaines entreprises
mais les failles il n'existe pas que
dans les entreprises privées lorsqu'on
voit lorsque nous collectivités locales
on est en est face à des des besoins de
contrôle des employés communaux avec un
exemple très simple celui des asem par
exemple en école maternelle
elles sont soumises à des visites tous
les deux ans peut beaucoup de
collectivités n'arrive pas à remplir
pourquoi parce qu'il ya plus de médecins
du travail et qui a plus de médecins
dans les centres de gestion
mais que fait l'état face à cela l'état
lui donne des délais beaucoup plus longs
pour le personnel enseignant et on
connaît tous des enseignants des
instituteurs qui ne voit jamais de
médecins du travail qui ne sont jamais
contrôlé alors qu'on exige deux ans pour
nos propres personnels
merci madame de roche je vais donc
mettre aux voix l'amendement 165
présents près par notre collègue pasquet
qui a reçu deux avis défavorables qui
est pour le voter merci qui est contre
merci mais chabrol est l'abstention il
n'est pas adopté nous en arrivons à
l'article 10 je mets au voile article 10
à monsieur longuet oui et oui et oui
mais cet article 10 et quand même
absolument passionnant parce qu'enfin
une rupture
mon collègue philippe bas vous a
interrogé madame le ministre sur les
ruptures
qu'avez vous décidé de supprimer de
cette course de ces constructions
scélérate qui depuis 1993 brise toute
espérance
en matière de retraites nous attendions
une réponse
nous avons un premier élément et nous
tenons à signaler
l'article 10 met fin à deux initiatives
importantes que la loi de 2010 avait
institué la première initiative
importante c'est d'avoir un conseil
scientifique en matière de d'études sur
la pénibilité création d'un comité
scientifique qui devait avoir lieu avant
qu'ils devaient se réunir j'imagine
avant le 31 mars 2011 et dont la mission
devait être d'évaluer les conséquences
de l'exposition aux facteurs de
pénibilité sur l'espérance de vie avec
et sans incapacité des travailleurs ce
un sujet passionnant je dois reconnaître
que nous aurions dû et les ministres
aval des émissions du travail successifs
sont en effet responsables de ne pas
avoir institué ce comité scientifique de
ne pas la voir réunis et ce comité
scientifique s'il l'avait été instituée
s'ils s'étaient réunis s'il avait
produit aurait pu
éclairer une partie du débat qui nous
mobilise depuis ce matin à savoir la
frontière entre pénibilité et santé la
frontière entre code du travail et code
de la sécurité sociale la frontière
entre l'organisation du travail avec un
regard de la médecine du travail mais
sous l'autorité du chef d'entreprise et
en liaison avec les représentants du
personnel d'une part et puis la médecine
de travail qui elle s'attaque à la santé
et sa dégradation ou son altération pour
reprendre les mots nous n'avons pas eu
le comité et donc nous ne savons pas
exactement où est la frontière où est la
borne est sans doute d'ailleurs
n'y at il pas de bornage précis ce
serait d'ailleurs bien le seul domaine
où des limites nous ne rions pas la
logique d ensemble flou et l'article 10
courageusement démoli détruit à bas une
ambition et une prétention de la
majorité précédente en matière de
retraite
enfin vous marquer une rupture puisque
vous constatez que la possibilité pour
les branches de mettre en place par
accord un dispositif d'allégement ou de
compensation de la charge du travail des
salariés occupés à des travaux pénibles
n'a pas été mis en place
il s'agissait de l'article 86 cette
expérimentation n'a pas abouti elle
devait prendre fin au 31 décembre 2013
pour vous dire encore une petite fille
nous quittons à l'hémicycle du sénat
mais nous allons bien entendu revenir
plus largement dans nos traditions de
19h sur la réforme des retraites a tout
de suite